yes he's done the right thing for
himself for the country
for the nhs of course he should have
come to this the prime minister boris
johnson should have shown
the guts the spine the judgment
to have sacked him you cannot have a
health secretary breaking the rules
in a pandemic when you need people to
follow
the rules and i think this reveals the
weakness lack of judgment lack of
leadership
from boris johnson that he didn't sack
him and if number 10 are briefing
tonight that this was matt hancock's
decision not boris johnson
i think that tells you even more so that
boris johnson
isn't cut out for the demands of
leadership is it fair to knock a man
when he's down here he is just
left his post i'm not knocking matt
hancock
as it happens it's a personal tragedy
for matt and
i i do send him my very best wishes he's
always been
personally courteous to me in all of our
dealings very grown-up dealings as you'd
expect
in a pandemic like this but to be frank
it's not just the last 24 hours which
call into question
matt hancock's abilities as the health
secretary he over these last 15 months
he failed to protect our care homes
he sent our nhs staff to the front line
in the face of a ferocious deadly virus
without the ppe that they needed contact
racing has been a shambles people still
aren't paid
money to isolate and we've got the virus
getting out of control again because of
the delta variant
which came to our shores because of
failures to put to secure our borders
so so there's been a litany of errors
15 months of missteps from mr hancock
but really this is about boris johnson
tonight and why did he not take
action when it was so obvious that he
needed to
could you argue that hancock has tried
his best during the pandemic here we are
with something that was
unheard of we don't know how to deal
with i mean would you have done any
better if you were
in government well in some ways he was
dealt a
a difficult hand because he inherited a
national health service with
a hundred thousand vacancies uh short of
forty thousand nurses an
nhs which had lost fifteen thousand beds
where an nhs and a social care sector
which had suffered from
tim shipman i haven't seen the tweet
from tim shipman
no uh i've well he has tweeted to
say about gina colladangelo's leaving
her position on the board of the
department of health we will be checking
that out for now but
uh jonathan ashworth you insist that
this
comes down on boris johnson yet we know
uh things have you've tried to uh put
things on him before haven't you look at
this
downing street refurbishment that didn't
help in the polls did it
well i don't i don't make interventions
based on the opinion polls
i make i make my public assertions on
what based on what is the correct
right and proper thing to do and when it
comes to the
mishandling of the pandemic it's obvious
that matt hancock sadly
failed but he also failed because he's
been part of a government which has
subjected our health care services to 10
11 years of
cutbacks we've lost 15 000 beds we were
short of
40 000 nurses there's been elements of
the nhs which have been outsourced
privatized
if you like so the foundations were
weakened going into this
pandemic we shouldn't have been in that
situation and that is because of the
policies that matt hancock and boris
johnson
not only supported but have ferociously
championed
over 10 years of tory government but
overall matt hancock has
done the right thing for the country
tonight but it should have been boris
johnson who showed leadership
uh on friday when this story broke of
course the
position now is vacant uh they're going
to be a number of key challenges
for whoever takes over who might take
over
any idea well i'd like to take over i
mean i want to be the health sector well
that's not going to happen yet is it
it's not
going to be for you not yet not yet uh
i mean i mean who knows but the
challenge for whoever takes over is how
you deal with the
waiting list which are now at record
levels over five million people
waiting for treatment but how do you
deal with the cancer waiting list which
have got longer where people's
uh life-saving treatments have been
delayed and cancelled how do you deal
with the mental health crisis where
young people
are struggling to access mental health
care i mean our waiting lists are so
large you can see them from out of space
now that's the challenge whoever the new
health secretary is
to deliver the quality care that
patients deserve and have been denied
and will labour give its unequivocal
support to whoever occupies this role
no we'll we'll hold the new health
secretary to account and we'll be asking
them
how are you going to drive down waiting
list now at 5 million
for the over 2 000 people waiting over
two years for treatment
imagine that waiting over two years for
treatment in pain and anxiety
one of those people gonna get their
operation and for the
the hundreds of thousands of people
waiting over a year when are they going
to get
their treatment or operation these are
the things i'm going to be asking the
new health secretary
and they'll need to convince me that
they've got a plan backed up by the
money
and with a plan to recruit the staff to
deliver that quality care
which too many people are being denied
at the moment
of course we were supposed to be talking
about so-called freedom day on the 21st
this week yet we're talking about
matt hancock aren't we now do you think
that what's
uh his breach of the certainly the
guidance
will affect people in that they think oh
they don't need to follow them well i
mean i hope not and that's why it's such
a difficult situation this if he had
stayed in place lots of people have said
well why should i follow
those rules it's why you had to go but
we have all got to follow the guidance
and we've got to get
the jabs get the vaccination if you've
been offered a vaccination
please take it because that ultimately
is how we get our freedoms back
and how we save lives what do you think
this does do to boris johnson's
credibility
now then the fact that he gave him his
support yesterday lunchtime
and now the health secretary has gone
and and the health secretary
looks like he has resigned rather than
uh being sacked
well it just shows you that boris
johnson has failed the test of
leadership
he should have stacked him and the fact
that even tonight they're saying
that mr hancock decided to resign rather
than
uh boris johnson asked him to leave his
post just shows you that
boris johnson has again as i say failed
the test of leadership and he's and he's
been
is now exposed as utterly lacking in any
judgment
um he has been fairly effective i mean
there's a lot of failures that you seem
to
lay mount hancock's matt hancock's adore
but look
at the vaccine the vaccines the
vaccination program that's under his
watch
well vaccination has gone well because
of the way in which primary care and our
nurses and the volunteers on the ground
have been able to deliver it but there's
so much has gone badly wrong
i mean infection rates are rising again
because the delta variant was allowed to
reach these shores because our borders
are left as secure as a sieve
and people are still not able to isolate
properly because they've not been paid
proper sick pay so there's been huge
failures throughout the last 15 months
i think the most the most serious of
which is the failure to protect care
homes
um i just want your reaction we firm
this up now uh gina carla d'angelo
is leaving her position on the board of
the uh department of health executive
director your your reaction to that well
that's the right thing to do
but nobody quite understands why she was
appointed or what the process was
although there's been lots of innuendo
about that
uh uh obviously because of the events of
recent days look
her appointment was murky it was lacking
in transparency
uh those are posts the people who do
those jobs are supposed to hold the
ministers to account in the department
i think it's right that she's resigned
she shouldn't have been appointed in the
first place